nos divertiremos con un juego que te
ayudará a desarrollar tus habilidades de
atención orientación y ubicación de
objetos en un espacio determinado solo
necesitas lápiz y papel detiene el vídeo
en lo que vas por ellos y una vez que
los tengas reinicia el vídeo para jugar
tu reino ha caído en manos de un rey
malvado que encerró a cinco de sus
principales guerreros en una torre de
diez pisos
si quieres recuperarlos debes entrar a
la torre enemiga y rescatar a tus
guerreros que se identifican con el
siguiente escudo
cuidado no te vayas a confundir
eligiendo a los enemigos que tienen este
símbolo en su escudo
para rescatarlos te presentar un mapa
como éste en donde deberás reconocer la
ubicación de tus guerreros y anotarla en
la hoja de papel para la ubicación
primero debes anotar el número de celda
en la que está capturado el guerrero
están numeradas del 1 al 7 1 2
y 7 también debes escribir el piso en el
que se encuentran tus guerreros los
pisos van del 1 al 10 1 2
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
puedes anotarlo de esta manera por
ejemplo guerrero 1 celda 3 piso 2
guerrero 2
celda 3 piso 5
y listo
utiliza este mapa para ubicar las
posiciones de los guerreros y
rescatarlos después debes de tener
cuidado ya que algunos de los guerreros
del rey están ocultos con mucha atención
detiene el vídeo y anota las ubicaciones
de cada guerrero en seguida inicia el
vídeo y veremos si has rescatado a los
guerreros correctos
muy bien revisemos las ubicaciones de
nuestros guerreros comenzando de abajo
hacia arriba
las posiciones de tus guerreros son las
siguientes el guerrero número uno está
en la celda 4 piso 3
el guerrero número 2 en la celda 2 piso
el guerrero 3 en la celda 7 piso 7
el guerrero 4 celda 7 piso 8
y el guerrero número 5 en la celda 1
piso 10
por último te dejo un nuevo mapa de otra
torre para que invites a un amigo y veas
quién es el primero en rescatar a sus
guerreros puedes copiar el dibujo en una
hoja en blanco y cuando cada uno haya
elegido un color diferente estarán
listos para empezar que te diviertas